das Wort hat zur Abgabe der
Regierungserklärung der Bundeskanzler
Herr Olaf Scholz
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen meine Damen und
Herren
der brutale Krieg in der Ukraine Putins
rücksichtsloser Einsatz von Hunger und
Energie als Waffe die enormen
Preissteigerung hier bei uns und
weltweit Deutschland und Europa gehen
durch Bewährungsproben wie wir sie seit
Jahrzehnten nicht erlebt haben
Bewährungsproben die Putin uns mit
seinem imperialistischen Angriffskrieg
aufgezwungen hat
der Krieg setzt menschliche Schwäche
voraus und gegen sie ist der gerichtet
schreibt Carl von klausewitz
Putin handelt danach aber zieht die
Ukraine mit Terror er droht der Welt
unverhohlen und vollkommen
verantwortungslos mit dem Einsatz von
Nuklearwaffen er will Angst sehen
Spalten und einschüchtern er spekuliert
auf unsere Schwäche
aber er irrt sich wir sind nicht schwach
unser Land steht zusammen Europa steht
zusammen und zeigt Solidarität
untereinander und mit der Ukraine unsere
weltweiten Allianzen sind stark und
lebendig wie nie putin wird seine
Kriegsziele nicht erreichen
als Putin den Krieg im Februar begann
haben manche gemutmaßt in wenigen Tagen
ist die Ukraine besiegt auch Putin
selbst hat das geglaubt
nun es ist anders gekommen es ist anders
gekommen weil die Ukrainer nur Ukraine
ihr Land so tapfer verteidigen und der
hohen schmerzhaften
Opfern befreien es ist anders gekommen
aber auch deshalb weil die Partner der
Ukraine darunter auch wir das Land
unterstützt haben politisch finanziell
humanitär und mit Waffen
Artillerie und Luftabwehr ist genau das
was die Ukraine besonders dringend
braucht und genau das liefern wir
moderne Panzerhaubitzen und mehrfacher
Raketenwerfer zum Beispiel den
panzerringtausch mit Tschechien der
Slowakei Griechenland und Slowenien hat
manch einer auch in diesem Haus als
rohrkrippierer kritisiert inzwischen ist
klar auf diese Weise bekommt die Ukraine
rund 100 Panzer mit denen ihre Soldaten
sofort umgehen können
als eines der ersten Länder haben wir
der Ukraine Anfang Juni moderne
luftverteidigungssysteme zugesagt ein
erstes davon haben wir letzte Woche an
unsere ukrainischen Freunde übergeben
früher als ursprünglich geplant drei
weitere werden so schnell wie es geht
folgen
wir haben fliegerabwehrraketen geliefert
so wie Gepard Panzer über die es
zunächst auf schießt die bringen doch
nichts dafür gebe es nicht mal genügend
Munition heute sehen wir welchen
Unterschied sie ausmachen
wie überlebenswichtig unsere
Unterstützung ist das zeigen die
brutalen russischen Raketen und
Drohnenangriffe auf zivile Ziele die wir
in den vergangenen zwei Wochen erlebt
haben wahllos fallen ihnen Frauen Männer
und Kinder zum Opfer
ja selbst diejenigen die wie Sie sehr
geehrter Herr Schwarzmann den Terror und
die Verfolgung durch die
Nationalsozialisten überlebt haben
müssen erneut um ihr Leben fürchten dass
Sie heute hier unser Gast sind ehrt und
sehr
wir lassen auch die jüngsten Eskalation
moskauz nicht unbeantwortet mit einem
weiteren Sanktionspaket haben wir als EU
den Druck auf die russische Regierung
noch einmal erhöht bei diesem Kurs
bleibt es so lange Russland seinen
brutalen Angriffskrieg fortsetzt und
auch im Kreis der G7 Staats- und
Regierungschefs haben wir vergangene
Woche gemeinsam mit Präsident selensky
bekräftigt bewusste Angriffe auf die
Zivilbevölkerung sind Kriegsverbrechen
um es klar zu sagen auch eine solche
Taktik der verbrannten Erde wird
Russland nicht helfen den Krieg zu
gewinnen sie stärkt nur die
Entschlossenheit und den
Durchhaltewillen der Ukraine und ihrer
Partner
am Ende ist Russlands Bomben und Raketen
Terror eine Verzweiflungstat genauso wie
die Mobilisierung russischer Männer für
den Krieg
damit ist der Krieg endgültig im Herzen
der russischen Gesellschaft angekommen
in den Familien und auf der Straße
hunderttausende Russen entziehen sich
der Rekrutierung viele verlassen das
Land all die Lügen und Propaganda das
Gerede von
spezialoperationen und schnellen Siegen
alles nur Fassade wie ein Podium
die Ukraine wird sich erfolgreich
verteidigen und wir werden sie
unterstützen solange wie das
erforderlich ist
Putin hat geglaubt uns Europäer Spalten
zu können dort er hat das Gegenteil
erreicht
vor einigen Tagen beim Gründungstreffen
der europäischen politischen
Gemeinschaft haben sich 44 europäische
Staaten und die eu-institution zu dem
Grundsatz bekannt das Grenzen nicht mit
Gewalt verändert werden dürfen
niemand von uns und auch kein anderes
zivilisiertes Land der Welt akzeptiert
die fadenscheinigen Versuche Russlands
sich Teile der Ukraine unter den Nagel
zu reißen die illegalen scheinreferenten
in donetts luhanski
waren eine einzige Phase ihre Ergebnisse
sind null und nichtig
das müsste eigentlich auch die russische
Führung begreifen wenn sie sich das
Ergebnis der Abstimmung in der
Generalversammlung der Vereinten
Nationen letzte Woche anschaut
Nordkorea Syrien Nicaragua und Belarus
das waren die einzigen vier Länder die
mit Russland gestimmt haben
143 Staaten haben sich dagegen klar zur
Souveränität und zur territorialen
Integrität der Ukraine bekannt sogar
noch etwas mehr als bei den Abstimmungen
im März nach Ausbruch des Krieges
zugleich stellen sich viele die Frage
wie Putins irrsinniger Krieg beendet
werden könnte am meisten jedoch sehen
sich wohl die ukraineren Ukrainer selbst
nach Frieden
Präsident selenski ist Bereitschaft zu
einem gerechten Frieden ist daher kaum
hoch genug einzuschätzen im engen
Kontakt mit unseren Freunden in Kiew
haben wir als G7 erst vor wenigen Tagen
erklärt was es hierzu aus unserer Sicht
Bedarf
gerecht bedeutet dass es sich nicht um
ein diktatfrieden handelt sondern dass
die Souveränität die territoriale
Integrität und auch die
Verteidigungsfähigkeit der Ukraine
gewährleistet sind heute und in Zukunft
unsere Bereitschaft der Ukraine mit
Blick auf eine tragfähige Friedenslösung
langfristige sicherheitszusage zu geben
haben wir ebenfalls als G7 erneut
bekräftigt
auch beim heute beginnenden Europäischen
Rat werden wir über die weitere
Unterstützung der Ukraine beraten die
gute Nachricht ist der Finanzbedarf
Kiews bis Jahresende ist praktisch
gedeckt die EU und die G7 spielen dabei
eine entscheidende Rolle doch der Krieg
und seine Folgen werden uns noch auf
viele Jahre beschäftigen
umso wichtiger ist es dass wir heute
schon überlegen wie wir die Ukraine in
den kommenden Jahren beim Wiederaufbau
unterstützen wer die Bilder aus den von
Russland befreiten ukrainischen Städten
und Dörfern sieht der versteht
das wird eine Generationenaufgabe bei
der die gesamte zivilisierte
Staatengemeinschaft ihre Kräfte bündeln
muss
deshalb haben Ursula von der Leyen und
ich als Präsident der G7 der
wirtschaftsstarken Demokratien kluge
Köpfe aus Wissenschaft Wirtschaft und
Zivilgesellschaft für den 25 Oktober
nach Berlin eingeladen
bei einer internationalen
Expertenkonferenz werden sie ihre
Vorschläge für einen langfristigen
verlässlichen und transparenten
Wiederaufbau der Ukraine zusammenführen
und so Input liefern für ein
internationalen marschallplan für die
Ukraine
engere europäische und internationale
Koordinierung brauchen wir auch bei der
militärischen Unterstützung der Ukraine
diesen Vorschlag hatte ich bei meiner
Rede an der Prager Karls-Universität
Ende August gemacht seither ist diese
Idee weiter vorangekommen am Montag
haben sich die Uhr Außenminister auf
eine neue ausbildungsmission für ca
15.000 ukrainische Soldaten und Soldaten
hier in der EU geeinigt eines der beiden
Hauptquartiere wird sich in Deutschland
befinden bis zum Frühjahr werden wir
eine vollständige Brigade mit bis zu
5.000 Soldaten ausbilden damit
unterstreichen wir unsere Bereitschaft
und dauerhaft am Aufbau starker
ukrainischer Streitkräfte zu beteiligen
Hand in Hand mit unseren Partnern
im Licht der zeitenwände stellen wir
auch unser Land sicherheitspolitisch neu
auf
dafür steht das Sondervermögen für die
Bundeswehr dafür steht die
Refokussierung unser Streitkräfte auf
die Landes- und bündnisverteidigung und
die Übernahme größerer Verantwortung an
der östlichen Flanke der Allianz dafür
steht die nationale Sicherheitsstrategie
an der wir intensiv arbeiten und der
verstehen die Vorschläge zur
sicherheitszusammenarbeit in Europa die
ich in meiner Rede in Prag skizziert
habe
und ich freue mich dass die Idee einer
engeren europäischen Kooperation bei der
Luft Verteidigung so schnell von 14
europäischen Ländern aufgegriffen wurde
die dabei mit uns zusammenarbeiten
wollen das ist genau die Art von
seinergie die Art von
klugerarbeitsteilung wie wir sie für die
Sicherheit Europas jetzt brauchen
Russlands Krieg hat aber nicht nur
tiefgreifende Folgen für Europa weltweit
hat er für Engpässe bei Nahrungsmitteln
und Dünger gesorgt mit fatalen Folgen
830 Millionen mehr als jeder zehnte
Weltbürger hat laut aktuellen Zahlen
nicht genug zu essen
Putin nimmt das nicht nur in Kauf er
nutzt Hunger als Waffe
wir müssen uns auch diese
Bewährungsprobe stellen das ist eine
Frage der Humanität das ist aber auch
eine Frage der Glaubwürdigkeit
wenn wir wollen dass die Länder Afrikas
Asiens Lateinamerikas und der Karibik
uns auch künftig dabei unterstützen das
Völkerrecht gegen Aggressionen wie die
russische zu verteidigen dann ist es nur
recht und billig dass wir auch Ihre
Sorgen im Umgang mit den Folgen des
russischen Krieges ernst nehmen
in der Europäischen Union haben wir
dafür sehr früh damit begonnen
Alternative exportwege für ukrainisches
Getreide aufzubauen per Bahnen oder per
Schiff zum Beispiel über die Donau wir
haben die Vereinten Nationen und die
Türkei in den Verhandlungen über eine
Öffnung des Seewegs im Schwarzen Meer
unterstützt und wir greifen Ländern
weltweit unter die Arme die mit Hunger
Ernte Ausfällen und steigenden Preisen
für Brot und andere Grundnahrungsmittel
zu kämpfen haben
eines der zentralen Ziele unserer
g7-präsidentschaft war die Gründung
eines Bündnisses für globale
Ernährungssicherheit ich bin froh dass
uns das gelungen ist
und mit den diesjährigen Zusagen der G7
in Höhe von 14 Milliarden Dollar haben
wir zunächst zumindest eine Chance eine
globale
Hungerkatastrophe abzuwenden
meine Damen und Herren auch Energie
setzt Putin als Waffe ein lange vor der
Zerstörung der nordstream Pipelines in
der Ostsee hat Russland bereits seine
Lieferung durch Nord Stream 1
eingestellt ohne nachvollziehbaren Grund
und deshalb
dieses Russland unter Putin ist kein
zuverlässiger Handelspartner mehr
für uns und für die gesamte Welt
bedeutet das auf dem Weltmarkt fehlt ein
Großteil der 55 Milliarden Kubikmeter
Gast die Russland zuletzt durch
Pipelines nach Europa geliefert hat
Putin hat gehofft uns mit dem Abdrehen
des gasthahns erpressen zu können
doch auch da hat er sich verrechnet
denn Europa steht zusammen und auch wir
als Land haben mit den Maßnahmen der
vergangenen Woche und Monate
sichergestellt dass wir voll Zuversicht
sagen können gemeinsam kommen wir wohl
durch diesen Winter
in Windeseile haben wir alternative
importstrukturen aufgebaut die ersten
flüssigkeitsterminals in Wilhelmshaven
Brunsbüttel gehen zum Jahreswechsel ans
Netz auch erste Lieferung über Lupinen
können dann möglicherweise erfolgen
weitere Terminals werden im Laufe des
kommenden Jahres hinzukommen
seit einer Woche fließt erstmals
überhaupt Gas aus Frankreich zu uns auch
die Kapazitäten an den westeuropäischen
Häfen in den Niederlanden und Belgien
nutzen wir um zusätzliches Gast zu
beschaffen
verlässliche Partner wie Norwegen haben
ihre Lieferungen an uns erhöht mit dem
USA und Ländern der arabischen Halbinsel
haben wir neue Lieferverträge
abgeschlossen weitere sind in
Vorbereitung
mit all diesen Maßnahmen haben wir
geschafft unsere Speicher in Deutschland
Europa rechtzeitig vor dem Winter zu
füllen anders als übrigens im Vorjahr
der den Füllstand von 95 Prozent den wir
in Deutschland zum ersten November
erreichen wollten haben wir schon
unterschritten überschritten das ist
eine große Leistung
wir haben entschieden dass wir
Kohlekraftwerke wieder ans Netz nehmen
erst in diesen Tagen sind fünf weitere
braunkohlekraftwerksblöcke in der
Lausitz und im Rheinischen Revier
hinzugekommen als zeitlich begrenzte
aber notwendige Notfallmaßnahme
Notfallmaßnahme denn wir stehen weiter
fest zu unseren erklärten Klimazielen
wir sorgen dafür dass wir alle drei noch
laufenden Atomkraftwerke den gesamten
Winterland nutzen können so hat es das
Kabinett gestern auf den Weg gebracht
und schließlich haben Unternehmen den
Umstieg von Gast auf andere
Energiequellen erleichtert für Switch
leitet das Stichwort
das alles steckt Deutschlands und
Europas Energiesicherheit
hinzu kommen die sparanstrengung vieler
Bürgerinnen und Bürger und auch
zahlreiche Unternehmen ich bin dafür
außerordentlich dankbar
gemeinsam wollen wir unseren Gast
Verbrauch um 20% senken denn jede
Kilowattstunde die wir einsparen stärkt
unsere Energiesicherheit
und ich bin froh
und ich bin froh dass es uns gelungen
zur auf europäischer Ebene auf ein
einspazier von 15 Prozent beim
gastverbrauch zu einigen das ist ein
starkes Signal europäischer Solidarität
gerade auch gegenüber unserem Land das
bislang ganz besonders von russischen
Gast abhängig war
abhängig war wohlgemerkt denn wir haben
uns aus der Abhängigkeit befreit und
gehen zugleich gut vorbereitet in den
kommenden Winter
und noch etwas möchte ich erwähnen wenn
wir über Energiesicherheit reden unsere
Sicherheitsbehörden die Bundespolizei
die Dienste des Bundeskriminalamt das
PSI tun alles um gemeinsam mit den
Betreibern unsere kritischen
Infrastrukturen zu schützen auch mit den
Partnern in der NATO in der Europäischen
Union sind wir dazu intensivem
Abstimmung mit Schweden und Dänemark
stimmen wir uns eng bei der Aufklärung
des sabotageakts gegen die beiden
nordstream-pipelines ab
auf See zeigen Marine und Bundespolizei
mit allen verfügbaren Kräften und
Schiffen Präsenz und noch in diesem Jahr
wollen wir Eckpunkte beschließen für ein
dachgesetz zum besseren Schutz
kritischer Infrastrukturen
wir wissen absolute Sicherheit kann es
angesichts der Größe und Komplexität
kritischer Infrastrukturen nicht geben
aber auch hier gilt wir sorgen vor und
vor allem wir lassen uns nicht
einschüchtern
meine Damen und Herren die
Energiesicherheit ist das eine die viel
zu hohen Energiepreise sind eine andere
große Bewährungsprobe für unser Land und
für Europa
keine Frage die Preise für Strom und
Wärme für Gas Öl und Kohle müssen runter
und zwar auf einen für die Bürgerinnen
und Bürger und für unsere Unternehmen
verträgliches Maß auch das wird zu Recht
Thema sein beim Europäischen Rat heute
und morgen in Brüssel
wir haben beschlossen hier in
Deutschland eine strompreisbremse
einzuführen analog zu Entscheidungen auf
europäischer Ebene an der Umsetzung
arbeiten wir aktuell mit Hochdruck Ziel
ist Bürgern und Bürger so rasch wie
möglich für ein grundkontingent von
Strom zu entlasten
wir sind dabei den europäischen Weg
gegangen und haben in weniger Wochen
Mehrheiten in Europa zustande bekommen
das zeigt die EU ist in diesen Fragen
handlungsfähig und die Bundesregierung
wird immer darauf achten diese
europäische Handlungsfähigkeit zu
stärken
bei den Preisen für Gast und Wärme ist
das Ganze komplizierter denn der
Gaspreis wird von Knappheiten auf dem
Weltmarkt bestimmt
aber auch hier sind wir auf europäischer
Ebene schon weit gekommen so werden wir
beim Europäischen Rat heute darüber
sprechen unsere Nachfrage zu bündeln
ich bin der Europäischen Kommission
daher dankbar für Ihre Vorschläge
Einkaufsgemeinschaften europäischer
Unternehmen möglich zu machen die
gemeinsamen Gast kaufen können richtig
ist auch ein Teil der Kapazität der
europäischen gastspeicher im nächsten
Jahr gemeinsam zu befüllen
mit dem Modell Trading hat Europe haben
wir gezeigt wie das gehen kann
auch über die Entwicklung eines
ergänzenden gaspreisindexes zum TTF
werden wir uns Gedanken machen der
Bezugspunkt sein kann für künftige
gasimport Verträge
das beste Mittel
gegen ein zu knappes Angebot aber bleibt
der schnelle Ausbau der erneuerbaren
Energien die Kommission hat dazu bereits
Vorschläge für einfache
Planungsverfahren gemacht das sollte nun
auch für die großen Übertragungsnetze
geschehen auch dafür werde ich mich beim
Europäischen Rat stark machen
um die Ausfallenden russischen
gastliefern zu ersetzen müssen wir
außerdem mit Ländern zusammenarbeiten
indem die Möglichkeit zu Erschließung
neuer gastfelder besteht natürlich im
Rahmen unserer Verpflichtung aus dem
Pariser Klimaabkommen
wir werden auch darüber sprechen wie wir
mit Preisspitzen umgehen die Vorschläge
der Kommission dazu schauen wir uns sehr
genau an
ein politisch Gesetz der preisdeckel
wirkt aber immer das Risiko dass die
Produzenten ihr Gast dann anderswo
verkaufen und wir Europäer am Ende nicht
mehr Gas bekommen sondern weniger
deshalb muss sich die EU mit anderen
gastkonsumenten etwa mit Japan und Korea
eng abstimmen damit wir uns nicht
gegenseitig Konkurrenz machen und
zugleich sprechen wir auch mit den
Produzenten über einen angemessenen
Preis
ich bin überzeugt Länder wie die USA
Kanada oder Norwegen die gemeinsam mit
uns solidarisch an der Seite der Ukraine
stehen haben ein Interesse daran dass
Energie in Europa nicht unbezahlbar wird
auch im g7-kreis sprechen wir darüber
schließlich wurde die G7
bzw damals noch die Gesetze als Antwort
auf die erste Ölkrise der 70er Jahre und
die Zusammenbruch des
breitenwood-systems gegründet damals ist
es in diesem Rahmen gelungen die Welt
gemeinsam zurück auf einen Wachstumspfad
zu führen und das ist auch mein Ziel als
g7-vorsitzender heute
parallel nutzen wir natürlich auch die
Möglichkeiten die wir als
Volkswirtschaft haben um die gast- und
Wärmepreise auf ein verträgliches Maß zu
senken dem dient der wirtschaftliche
Abwehrschirm von bis zu 200 Milliarden
Euro der unter anderem die
gaspreisbremse beinhaltet
eine Kommission aus Wissenschaftlerinnen
und Wissenschaftlern
arbeitgebervertretern Gewerkschaften
Stadtwerke und Energieversorgern hat uns
Anfang letzter Woche ein klugen
Vorschlag gemacht wie wir die
Preissteigerung für Gas- und Fernwärme
stark begrenzen können
die vorgeschlagenen Maßnahmen haben
eines gemeinsam sie halten Energie
bezahlbar wirken schnell und Hebel
zugleich einspar-
wir setzen diesen Vorschlag nun um
spätestens im März nächsten Jahres
erhalten alle Bürgerinnen und Bürger mit
Gast oder Fernwärme ein vergünstigtes
basiskontingent und um schon früher für
Entlastung zu sorgen hat die Kommission
und empfohlen dass die Versorger das
Geld für Abschlagszahlung im Dezember
vom Staat erhalten
auch Unternehmen kleine und große werden
gezielt entlastet und deshalb können wir
heute sagen niemand keine Familie keine
Rentnerin kein Student und auch kein
Unternehmen soll Angst haben vor den
Preisen für Strom Gas oder Fernwärme
überfordert zu werden
unseren Abwehrschirm haben wir bewusst
auf zweieinhalb Jahre angelegt um auch
für den nächsten Winter gewappnet zu
sein auf diesen Zeitraum gerechnet
entsprechen die 200 Milliarden Euro um
die zwei Prozent unseres
Bruttoinlandsprodukts das liegt in der
Größenordnung der Pakete die in diesem
Jahr auch anders wo in Europa geschnürt
wurden und werden in Frankreich in
Italien oder in Spanien zum Beispiel
die Europäische Union verfügt zudem über
genügend finanzielle Durchschlagskraft
um sich dieser Kriege entgegenzustellen
aus der Aufbau und resilienzfassilität
die wir während der corona-pandemie
gemeinsam beschlossen haben ist bislang
erst ein Fünftel ausgezahlt hier stehen
also noch über 600 Milliarden Euro zur
Verfügung die unsere Volkswirtschaften
stärken und für den Ausbau erneuerbarer
Energien genutzt werden können
dabei hilft uns auch die Einigung zur
Finanzierung von Repower EU die die
europäischen Finanzminister vor kurzem
erzielt haben damit wird ein
dreistelliger Milliardenbetrag aus den
Mitteln des Instruments next generation
EU genutzt und aufgestockt um uns
unabhängig zu machen von fossiler
Energie ich bin bereit zu schauen wie
wir diese und andere vorhandene Mittel
in der aktuellen Krise noch effizienter
einsetzen können
meine Damen und Herren diese europäische
Solidarität sorgt dafür dass die
Europäische Union Putins
energieerpressung standhält
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen eines
dürfen wir aber über all die
Bewährungsproben für die uns Putins
Angriffskrieg gestellt hat nicht aus den
Augen verlieren unser Ziel aus der
Nutzung fossiler Ressourcen auszusteigen
der schnelle Ausbau erneuerbare Energien
und der Netze sowie mehr
Energieeffizienz sind die beste
Strategie damit unsere Energieversorgung
sicher bleibt und wieder bezahlbar wird
jedes Windrad an Land oder auf See jede
Photovoltaikanlage macht uns ein Stück
unabhängiger von teurem Gast oder Öl
der Umbau des Energiesektors die
Transformation unserer Industrie die
Modernisierung unserer Gebäude der
Ausbau der Bahnung des Nahverkehrs der
Hochlauf der Elektromobilität und der
Wasserstoffwirtschaft das sind daher die
zentralen Aufgaben dieses Jahrzehnts
und die Weichen dafür sind gestellt wir
haben die umfassendste Novelle des EEG
des letzten Jahrzehnts verabschiedet wir
beschleunigen den Ausbau der Offshore
Windkraft im Februar kommenden Jahres
wird das Windenergie an Landgesetz in
Kraft treten das 2% der Fläche unseres
Landes für die Windkraft zur Verfügung
stellt noch im Herbst wollen wir ein
weiteres Paket zur
planungsbeschleunigung beschließen denn
was ich Anfang dieses Jahres versprochen
habe das halten wir ein alle Regeln alle
wichtigen Gesetze die es braucht damit
Deutschland seine Klimaziele erreicht
die stehen bis zum Jahresende
auch auf EU-Ebene halten wir Kurs wir
wollen in den kommenden Monaten eine
endgültige Einigung auf das fit for
fifty five Paket herbeiführen als
Booster für den internationalen
Klimaschutz beim Anstehen der
Europäischen Rat werden wir unsere
Position für die anstehende
Weltklimakonferenz in Sharm el Sheikh
abstimmen die russische Aggression und
ihre Folgen dürfen nicht zu einer
weltweiten Renaissance der Kohle führen
deshalb werden wir klare Angebote machen
damit auch Entwicklungs- und
Schwellenländer den Weg in Richtung
eines klimaneutralen Energiesektors
geschlossen entschlossen gehen und wir
werden den Staaten entschlossen helfen
die schon heute besonders unter den
Folgen des Klimawandels leiten
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen die
Bewährungsproben unserer Zeit erfordern
neues Denken und mutiges Handeln von
jedem von uns
im Eiltempo und oft unter größten
Handlungsdruck haben wir in den
vergangenen Monaten weitreichende
zukunftsweisende Entscheidung getroffen
für Europa für unser Land für seine
Bürger und Bürger dabei haben wir
miteinander immer wieder um den besten
Weg gerungen und werden das auch
weiterhin tun denn auch das ist wichtig
in einer Autokratie wie Russland ist das
Ziel größtmögliche Uniformität
Kreativität und Widerspruch werden
bestraft mutige Oppositionelle
verschwinden auf Jahre in Gefängnissen
oder werden in den Ziel gezwungen nicht
zuletzt das Schicksal einiger der
diesjährigen Friedensnobelpreisträger
erinnert uns an diese Schande
in Demokratien wie unserer aber liefern
unsere Debatten liefern freie Medien und
öffentliche Kritik immer wieder Anstöße
für Veränderung und den Fortschritt
darin liegt die Stärke offener
Gesellschaften darin liegt die Kraft der
Demokratie
diese Kraft diese Stärke meine Damen und
Herren unterschätzen Putin und seine
Gefolgsleute auf dramatische Weise und
deshalb bin ich sicherer denn je
Putins Kriegskurs gegen die Ukraine und
die gesamte freie Welt wird scheitern
eigentlich ist es schon längst
die Ukraine Deutschland und Europa aber
werden gestärkt aus diesen
Bewährungsproben hervorgehen geeinter
und unabhängiger als zuvor schönen Dank
ja der Bundeskanzler verharrte noch kurz
am Pult hat sich verneigt viel Applaus
aus dem ampelfraktionen für diese
Regierungserklärung von Olaf Scholz 30
Minuten hat er hier den großen Bogen
gespannt gleich am Anfang hat er gesagt
Putin spekuliert auf unsere Schwäche
aber er irrt sich Putin wird seine
Kriegsziele nicht erreichen er hat dann
die Solidarität der Europäer gelobt auf
dem europäischen Gipfel geschaut und
auch gesagt wenn Geld gebraucht wird in
dem corona-fonds sind noch 600
Milliarden Euro die man verbinden kann
dann hatte er im hinteren Teil den
innenpolitischen Teil sage ich mal
darauf hingewiesen dass diese
Bundesregierung alle Gesetze die
notwendig sind bis zum Jahresende
abschließen wird
[Applaus]